philosophy for our times is brought to
you in partnership with the new college
of the humanities a university level
college offering undergraduate and
postgraduate degrees in the heart of
London NCH pride themselves on offering
unprecedented access to a world-class
academic faculty philosophy students at
the college are taught by some of the
foremost scholars in the field and
one-to-one tutorials create a
personalized teaching experience choose
your major and minor for a unique
combined honours degree and study the
NCH diploma to widen your appreciation
of the world in ways you'd never thought
of before go to NC h london dot a c dot
uk'
for more information think better think
NC h hello and welcome to philosophy for
our times the podcast which brings the
world's leading thinkers to debate
today's biggest ideas today we are
thinking about life beauty and being
this week our speakers take on life
beauty and being by going in search and
answer to what is beauty so once beauty
was about goodness and truth but now we
think it means little more than models
products and outdated art beauty is a
central guiding principle in most
societies but from mana to Kim
Kardashian can we really define what
beauty is have practical concerns and
the economy of desire made beauty
trivial and expendable or could we
follow Goethe and Kant and cultivate our
aesthetic judgment to enrich our lives
going in search of beauty to enrich our
lives this week we have a director of
the public sphere
Justin clutter founder of Coco de Mer
Sam Roddick and philosopher and film
critic Benson on a
as ever we'd love to know what you
thought of this week's episode so do get
in touch and let us know what you
thought head over to iTunes to give us a
rating or review we love producing this
podcast for you for free and we'd love
to continue to do so for as long as
possible so please do subscribe to day
to never miss an episode and have a look
at all the podcasts and get downloading
back now to daniel sun's your host this
week's episode so the question they will
be responding to first is is the goal of
living beautifully a conceit of the
privileged elite and we'll start with
you Justine hello everyone yes so I very
strongly believe that it is not I think
that first of all we have to talk about
definitions how I think that popularly
when we talk about beauty now people do
associate it with models and fashion and
everything that I think contorts the
true definition of beauty which is in
the more I see it in the more platonic
set senses the kind of abstract form
it's connected to the good and the true
and something that is a kind of guiding
principle of our life that we find in
many different areas be it in looking at
a beautiful sunset or seeing a beautiful
interaction between two people or
looking at a piece of Arts that somehow
elevates us as as human beings and to me
that is not trivial at all and in fact I
think that's the the essence of morality
is grounded in that kind of conception
of beauty the essence of being a human
is grounded in that conception of beauty
and so I think oftentimes when when
people associate beauty with with other
things and they say it's it's not
significant it's not consequential it's
because they're thinking of it in this
more modern sense where it is connected
but I'd like to completely separate the
two because if we confuse them at all
we're talking about something entirely
different so from my perspective my
research is grounded in this idea of the
beautiful soul and this was kind of
grounded in the Enlightenment principles
of you know striving towards rationality
striving towards equality tribe striving
towards kind of scientific truth but
there was also kind of at the bridge
between enlightenment and Romanticism
and then
to play with the emotions and the
significance of feeling and experiences
in the world and encounters with people
these these things were united in this
concept and essentially the idea of the
beautiful soul which we now would
dismiss in the age of Trump I think to
think about the beautiful soul sounds
ridiculous but I think you'll see more
and more that's something that I think a
very pragmatic approach the world in
politics and in in economics in society
has kind of branded as insignificant we
will see with the total demise of values
that this again becomes very significant
precisely because it holds a kind of
more objective truth and so in relation
to this I mean I would just say that
this concept the basic idea was that you
could kind of cultivate yourself almost
like a person sculpting a sculpture you
can sculpt away the impurities
essentially the idea was in your soul
you we often think about physical health
we think how are you know body operates
but we never think about the condition
or the state of our soul and if everyone
did that every day I think it would have
huge implications for how we treat other
humans how we interact in the world are
we living a life of value and meaning
and so a lot of this was thinking about
okay well our individuals actions in the
world a lot of it was thinking about
this objective you know cultivating
virtues cultivating a kind of sense of
self in relation to others but it was
ultimately directed at the objective a
kind of collective good so it was while
it was very subjective and
individualistic it was for the sake of
humanity because the idea was in line
was a kind of consi an idea that
enlightenment is you you know the French
Revolution the chaos that happened in
you know something that was so good but
then but then eventually led to the
terror if there's kind of dogmatic
action that's unreflective it won't lead
to any more clarity or truth it will
only lead to chaos and madness and so
the idea was kind of taking up that
Conte in principle of we each are kind
of a very significant person like being
in the world that is a unit in the
society and if we don't realize our
potential if we don't cultivate latent
potential then we are not being you know
active moral agents and that's
essential to larger frameworks of
morality so I think so I guess I'm out
of time probably but yeah I think it's
absolutely fundamental in that sense
fantastic thanks dusty and that's a
really great start for us Ben sir
Thanks so the question is whether Beauty
is the privilege of the elite yes
so I'm my guess is that very few people
would say that it is and I guess you
know that would be a bold position so
I'm gonna take that ball position so I
think that beauty at least in some sense
in some sense of the terms traditionally
understood is the privilege of the elite
and that's why we should not care about
beauty in that sense maybe we should
care about beauty in a different sense
so maybe it's a definitional question so
we're gonna see that I guess later but I
I do want to argue that much of what we
care about in the world of art is not
beauty anymore that may have been beauty
in the 17th century with Lauren's little
landscapes and stuff but not really
anymore that's not why we go to two
exhibitions it's not where we go to the
cinema that's not why we go to the
theater or not we go to concerts what
the reason why we do go to these events
is to get experiences that are really
rewarding for us special kind of
experiences and some of those
experiences are what was being
traditionally described as beautiful but
not all of them are gonna be that so so
I think it in some sense it's been a big
mistake for aesthetics the philosophy or
discipline to be obsessed with beauty
because beauty is just one aspect of
what we find interesting or exciting
about about art and it would be a good
idea for if you want to understand our
engagement with artworks to to kind of
widen our horizon and to focus on
because disengage with this obsession
with beauty and and focus on various
kinds of experiences of all kinds that's
not [ __ ] thank you
well I'm kind of interested in the
concept of beauty in how I personally
experience beauty
then also the political interplay that
it has within our lives and then
actually from an economic point of view
where the commodification of beauty
comes in so there these three areas of
beauty that I personally interact with
and I was really thinking about it
because what does the experience of
beauty really feel like and when do you
actually get to observe beauty and what
state are you in
and I think that is a really interesting
question and I wanted to come up with an
example where actually beauty shifts and
changes with biorhythms and that
sometimes is from an emotional
perspective but then also through
political kind of errors without within
history what is considered culturally
beautiful also shifts and you're seeing
that kind of speed up as kind of ascetic
styles are kind of get dumped and put
into the landfill and new ones arise and
old ones get reborn so the way I wanted
to describe my emotional interplay with
Beauty was how I can see somebody who's
asymmetrical and very typical I can
immediately find them an extraordinary
example of physical beauty and as I get
to know them various realities of their
characteristics start to paint a hue on
their features that allows me either to
redefine somebody who might be
immediately not very attractive into
somebody who is stunningly attractive
that comes and their aesthetic shifts as
you either emotionally bond or find them
kind of repugnant somebody very
beautiful can shift into a form of
ugliness in front of your eyes so when
you actually have this you can start to
realize that your emotional landscape
actually feeds your perception and that
can be ever shifting all the time and I
think that's a really important
perspective to hold and also when do we
see a beautiful kind of sunset as
beautiful we have to be in a state of
observation because we can walk past
beautiful experiences every day like a
symphony of birds and all we
hearing is our thoughts or our stresses
and we actually kind of can blank out
these kind of extraordinary kind of
feelings of present nurse because
actually observing beauty requires us to
step out of ourselves and actually be an
observant or character now the most
important question is have we changed or
have we commodified beauty and made it
of an economic value there's somebody
who is more beautiful hold a more value
social value and therefore is more
rewarded with in our economic society if
they hold the right features that we can
recognize them with and is somebody who
is ugly penalized for that but also that
also comes in with actually the history
of what we culturally have defined as
beautiful has always been dictated by
the politics of the wealthy from
religion from the the the color blue
that the Virgin Mary was painted it was
illegal for any artist to use it other
than that it was the most precious color
the actual geometrics of a temple was
controlled and you were kind of kind of
physically penalised by the church if
you actually made a church to dis
proportions of the golden mean and so I
think that is also the fact that
actually beauty is about exclusivity
there is there is not necessarily in
terms of a cultural perception and of
course we have situations where artists
die and suddenly their art is considered
beautiful where it was valueless before
so there are all of these factors
attached to it that we have to kind of
realize from the emotional experience to
the actual cultural dictation of what is
socially acceptable as beauty and what
that means to us is an individual and
where does that in congruence lie
between our experience and where culture
and the wealthy are using it and
politics and religion is using it
therefore as a way to conform as a form
of conformity thank you my pitch is it
over yes I wonder whether it might be
good at this point to think about
definitions of beauty how
we go about defining it should we define
it and how if you had to define it how
would you do it
Justine well I would just I mean I think
my sense of beauty is very much as I
already said platonic and also kind of
18th century 19th century German
philosophy really picks up on the
Platonic ideas and one con I mean I'm
not sure if this is it isn't a
definition but I think it illuminates
this this debate a bit is that this
Schopenhauer an idea of like the
experience of the beautiful is one that
if in the world where your will is
perpetually striving for something you
can suspend your will and in in that
moment you're completely present in the
experience of the work of art or the
experience of nature and that does
something I mean beyond Schopenhauer
that does something when we for example
are able to reflect on the intricacy of
a leaf you know in all its beauty when
we have that level of perception of the
world and that extends to a much more
transcendental understanding of beauty I
think we're better able to empathize
with others just a simple example of
looking for example reading a book
you're completely immersed in the
narrative of that person and if that
person has lived a very different life
from you you're suddenly able to
empathize with them in a similar way to
children you know when they're playing
in the garden they see a butterfly they
want to share that experience it's one
conducive to reciprocity whereas and
once you enter something material it's
the exact opposite effect so I think
that's why again I want to completely
separate a kind of you know culture I
mean I absolutely agree with in this
sense of the word beauty is exclusive
but that's very different than an
inclusive Universal understanding of
beauty which you can find in in nature
and and very many other experiences so
maybe that I don't know to me beauty is
very much connected with empathy
understanding a kind of vivid perception
of the world that illuminates everything
and makes it poetic and when you enter
that state of being you you in turn are
more receptive to experiences in the
world there's a creativity that comes
into play there's a kind of connection
to for example fractals of systems in
nature a kind of understanding it's it
gives us a guide to more objective
truths so thank you
I can actually pick up on something from
this so um said what you're describing
I'm going back to shopping Harris is an
experience that's clearly very important
for some of us it's this kind of
detached experience of the world when
we're somehow without being interested
in what in the purpose of this object we
are just contemplating its formal
properties in a detached way something
like that and I and I think this is a
really important experience in fact I
wrote a book about it called aesthetics
s philosophy of perception I think
people who were much better at
describing in than shoppin however for
example Prost Prost was going on about
exactly that kind of experience and
sometimes very very perceptive about
about it and in other people like coming
for example and also the Kirikou there's
a lot of kind of cool quotes that you
can the other key you can look for this
well here is my problem I think that
this experience is both geographically
and temporally very limited so I think
this is something that probably it was
not there before the 17th 18th century
and it's on its way out that is my
thought and it's also very very
geographically restricted to Europe it's
not something that you're gonna you're
gonna find outside your so that's it so
alright I really I deeply care about
this kind of experience because you know
I was raised in Europe in that part of
human history but I think we should see
that that's the thing that that's what
it's all about is a bit I don't know how
to say it colonialist both
geographically and also temporally but
so are you saying then that Justine's
claim that we can have an inclusive
understanding of beauty is wrong
I just think no no I think that that's
what we should do so I think that on a
very general level beyond complete
agreement because I think that what we
should try to achieve is some kind of
really inclusive thing understanding of
beauty that covers lots of other things
other than this kind of Schopenhauer
asked Austrian experience but I think
that there's reason to think that this
kind of this disengaged disinterested
attention way of engaging with the world
in the age of smartphones it's on its
way out our kids they're not going to
know what it is that or if they do
our grandkids are not gonna wear it is
they gonna have a completely different
conception of what beauty is or what
what kind of experiences are worth
having when you go to when you're when
you have an aesthetic experience so I
think I don't know I just want to warn
that we should be aware of our
limitations on this concept maybe this
is good for you to jump back in do we
need a new notion of beauty well I think
there is there's a personal truth within
that and that as I bring it back down to
experience like so what I find
fascinating when you talk about nature
and you talk about structure and you
talk about design that actually as human
beings we are of nature and so I think
that a lot of times that beauty can
actually be distilled sometimes into
mathematics as well because there is
like certain structures that beauty
comes with and they're a part of it
there are different between like having
something very a symmetrical that is a
mirroring its own shape to being
irregular and it's this this fine line
between the two
so that I do think sometimes beauty does
come with a way that we want to kind of
visually harmonize and understand and
kind of categorize what we're viewing
but then within that there is an element
of our emotional experience which takes
us to the age-old pre probably
philosophical kind of accounts of
actually experiencing something other
than just what is here and it's almost
like an experience I'm I'm not religious
but and like experiencing God in that
kind of sense that is something so
beyond us and so mysterious so I think
sometimes like beauty is attached to
mystery of being of something of a shape
that kind of takes you out of yourselves
and gives you a gasp of breath so I it's
not like that I feel we should redefine
beauty but I feel like we all need to
familiarize ourselves with what do we
truly individually relate as beautiful
and see how it marries up to these
repetitive structures that come up and
we talk about fractals we talk about
snowflakes we talk about all of these
great
flowers and the formation of flowers and
leaves you can see their merit in
everything we build today and usually
what actually we respond to on a
biological level with all the scientific
research around responding to beauty is
we respond to somewhere in between
something that is asymmetrical and
irregular but if it's too asymmetrical
we actually start to not see the object
so I think that is for me more important
familiarizing ourselves with our own
emotional state what makes us react and
interact with beauty and how do we
individually define it I think that's
more honest I think the interesting time
to think about the relative between
beauty and morality
I mean you've mentioned this a couple of
times already Justine that the ethics
comes in very quickly and when you're
talking about beauty I wonder whether
you say but a little bit more about that
yes absolutely I mean first I would just
like to I I think it's very common in
the West among an elite for people to
say Beauty is elitist but actually when
you talk to people from other countries
who are not elite Beauty is one of the
first things they say keeps them going
it gives them a sense of purpose in the
world and so somehow I think we have
this
I just fundamentally disagree with the
idea that beauty is somehow something of
the 18th and 19th century reserves I
mean beauty is everywhere that's the
whole point it's Universal and to say
that I find is quite elitist because
it's almost presupposing that other
people don't have the capacity to feel
and experience beauty which to me
completely contradicts the whole point
so I think so many societies have been
founded on principles of beauty they've
used dance they've used song they've
used you know weaving techniques whoever
had that is all aesthetic that was all a
consideration of beauty and that was is
what holds communities together it's and
so this in turn I think ties in a bit
with this understanding of morality to
me beauty is a point of connection as I
was saying with the kind of sunset or
you know some very simple simplistic
experience like that you know somehow we
don't call you know for example you know
now in music people are talking about
money and wealth and like just and that
somehow is not elitist but then
experience something there's universal
like a sunset is and I just I find that
very problematic um and so I would say
that beauty the reason I think it's so
so can closely tied to morality is the
fact that it's connected to this
universality is is striving for the
universal and while we can all find
things that are subjectively beautiful
it's the ideas that were united by
something common and that it's it's a
communal undertaking we're sharing
something that is beyond ourselves it's
almost like a secular kind of religion
this is a unifying experience and that
we're able again I think here's where
perception comes in again but I think
just the ability if we dead in our
senses to the world then how can we
actually understand or empathize with
others I think so much of our deadens
morality are a deadened sensory
perception is is because we haven't
experienced beauty
we're so closed off to beauty that it's
very easy to forget everything else so
in in that sense I think it's kind of
beyond the just objective I I believe
personally I think this is more of a
based on faith than on empirical
evidence but I believe in these kind of
forms they're inextricably bound and I
agree they with what Sam said about like
a beautiful face becomes uglier
classically beautiful it's not you know
it's an embodied it's it's something
that's embody but actually the the
essence of it is the thing is the
personality it's the spirit so that is
what the truly beautiful thing and that
I think is where the beauty and truth
come into it so for plain and also
goodness but even if you don't take the
form as the subjective form that you
hold true
I think just in terms of looking at
examples of human societies and how they
work
beauty is something that connects sound
what do you think beautiful things
always good no well I I I'm I'm not
going to answer that question but I will
well no I don't think so it depends on
what you define like this you know you
can have a one can perceive a snake as
either beautiful or ugly so that I'm not
what I'm really interested in is the
economics historical economic structure
and how it has been used to alienate
that's what I'm into it and I think
that's a reality I don't think that
needs to continue to be
reality and there are an aspiration and
I agree with the aspiration but the
reality is even in tribal societies
there certain headdresses and certain
kind of materials that become
unattainable and there are certain
things that people can't eat there are
certain restrictions that actually
create a sense of hierarchy and that has
been going on for a very very very long
time and I think that is an interesting
kind of reality that we need to
deconstruct because it is unhealthy for
the masses for instance we've gone fat
we've gone thin in terms and now we're
going fat again in terms of our ascetic
of what is sexually kind of perceived as
an aspiration like in the 50s for
instance the the adverts were all about
fattening up post-war right there were
adverts in the very same way of all of
these diets that you can buy today or
health and well-being being kind of an
overarching kind of industry that pushes
you to feel neurotic about actually who
you are how you see yourself in the
mirror and what kind of unrealistic
expectations you should be having but
the truth is the majority of obese
people in our country are poor right and
that is seen as a kind of almost a sin
right in an old-fashioned sense you have
failed if you're obese but yet thin -
thin is also kind of an addictive state
of kind of neuroses and that is actually
kind of congratulated within our society
with extra thin models we're starting to
reconstruct this with Kim Kardashian's
bum but like you know that again is a
form of commodification and this isn't
new this is very very old within the
history of our kind of civil society so
yeah I think it's a problem Ben so do
you agree with Sam do you think that we
always need to think about the ways in
which aesthetics is politicized
I think it's telexes always
politicise and that's part of the reason
why I'm skeptical of the of this way of
thinking of beauty in this 18th century
manner because the politicizing at that
time it's very different from the
politicizing now but let me just say
something about the whose elitist that
was that uh so so uh it's like I guess
my point is that everyone has aesthetic
experiences that's a really important
part of who we are and that's that's
something we should really care about
our aesthetic experience is I'm just
gonna use the aesthetic experience and
not the concept beauty because I find
aesthetic experience less confusing
maybe I'm idiosyncratic but the kind of
aesthetic experience that Proust goes on
about and that's really important for me
personally
we should not generalize that either to
people who lived earlier or to people
who are gonna live later or to people
who live in different parts of the world
this is one kind of aesthetic experience
that you can have there's many other
kinds of aesthetic experiences
experiences that we find really
important and valuable to pay you know
big buck to get them at the field in
theater and then the exhibition is
finding a more useful term than Beauty
perhaps you could define aesthetic
experience for us I mean again exciting
experience has this kind of broader
sense and a narrower sense and the
broader sense is just experiences that
we deeply care about and we go out of
our way to have them and it's something
unless I can kind of restrict it a
little more but I think it's good to
keep it very broad because we have no
assurances that people in different
parts of the world or people who lived
earlier they can have very simply have
any kind of similar aesthetic experience
that we do so in the medieval times
people were not going they were not
having detached experiences of the of
the Madonna that's not that's not the
game that was that not what they were
they were supposed to do and but then
that's the kind of the more narrowly
construed ecstatic experience that I
think that that you're after and and
Schopenhauer and Proust and all these
people are after and this a way of
trying to understand it in terms of the
way I'm trying to understand this in
terms of attention that the idea is that
your attention is not focused on certain
features but it's distributed at
something it's when it's detached some
kind of detached distributed attention
that characterizes that experience yeah
but this just one final question um we
sort about talking more talking about
morality I mean would you say that as
that experiences it's a good thing it's
connected with the good in some way it's
a good thing it's good a good thing it's
a it's a very good thing to have life
would be really boring and and
irritating without it whether it's
whether there's I'm very skeptical about
this whole you know plate plate own but
you know Plato idea of the beautiful the
good and the true and they were all kind
of coming together that sounds a little
you know it would be nice but I just
don't think that that's that's really
the way they do you have an example
where ascetic has had a direct effect on
the social well-being of a community so
I work a lot with various different
organizations and NGOs and charities and
one of my favorite no longer exists and
it's called land life and it's a
wildflower organization and wildflowers
they only grow in kind of the worst soil
possible so if you have like kind of a
pummeled up concrete kind of earth like
from like from a demolition and plant
poppies there they gonna thrive right so
they go in there or they collect
wildflowers but they go into kind of
disenfranchised communities and they
were working in a community in Liverpool
in an estate that had a high crime rate
and then they went there and they kind
of shook up all of like the concrete
kind of like desert land and they
planted Everton blue cornflowers huge
amount of acreage in this estate and
they did this over a number of years and
they found that through this the
aesthetic beauty of just inundating with
these beautiful wildflowers throughout
the whole of spring and summer had such
a huge effect on the community that it
cut down crime it helped people to start
to interact it just had this over
arching kind of sense of beauty and
value but bringing that kind of emotion
that you're talking about which is
intangible and actually noncom
modifiable and I think that really that
was really moving and quite they did a
lot of social studies on it so I that's
an example of where actually ascetic can
hold a benevolence and in that kind of
sense can aid society into bettering
itself with the right energetic and the
right kind of intention I think often
it's the case like that's a really
beautiful example and exactly the type
of spirit that I'm getting at
I couldn't agree with I mean that's just
such a lovely example and I think
there's so many of them I think part of
the confusion and problem is that
oftentimes when something isn't in the
world we tend to deconstruct it so there
are no more ideals anymore or you know
we have a you know
political leaders who hold no you know
dignity so suddenly the world is that
but it doesn't have to be that it's very
easy to negate these things and to
contort their meaning because we are
frustrated with the fact that it isn't
true
and I think one of the things that's so
powerful about beauty is that of course
we all know that Kim Kardashian is not
not beautiful to me at least I mean I
don't know where personally sorry I
can't like just the fact that we have to
bring up this like to me morally hideous
person into the conversation it's
precisely the problem that that has to
come into the picture and sadly it does
because that's the way that we see it to
me is the grave insults to our society
and so I I mean I think that my point is
yes the world is like that is the
conception now but does it have to be
that way no and do we have to
deconstruct a sense of beauty because
that's the way the world is absolutely
not we can reek of elevate our ideals of
what these things are and hold ourselves
accountable just as we would with a
moral system event of any sort and I
think once we think in that way it's
quite liberating just suddenly examples
like Sam gave they're so powerful become
apparent and and we realize there's
actually a lot more accord everyone
agrees with that I mean I can't imagine
anyone who would say that that's not a
good thing and it didn't do something
you know valuable for a community so so
once we think in that way it's it's
actually very fruitful on to our final
theme which is the question of where we
go in the future
so should we be cultivating beauty or is
it something that we should be
abolishing that's that beauty in what
sense the idea of beauty I think I think
we can't really live without let's just
call it ecstatic experiences we can't
really get out of bed in the morning
unless we're looking forward to some
kind of valuable experiences that we're
gonna have that day do they have to be
beauty like that I'm not sure but again
that may there may be just the
definitional thing really the whole
disagreement to me which is about about
what what state what's the how we define
beauty but yeah so we so I think it's
immensely important to have these kind
of special experiences that you really
deeply care about so in that sense I
think beauty is something that we
clearly should not should not throw out
of our life and that's just know so we
couldn't well I would life would be very
difficult to live without it now they
you know the kind of contemplation of I
don't know Loran landscape you can do
without that right there's other ways of
getting this kind of aesthetic
experience then they can be traditional
things that we consider beautiful thing
so you're saying that if BT is a name
for some kind of an witching aesthetic
experience then fine we can keep it if
it's this more specific thing of the
detached experience and maybe not yeah I
mean maybe maybe for you the kind of
aesthetic experience it gets you out of
bed in the morning is not that you're
gonna go to the Louvre and you're going
to look at the Vermeer for three hours
you know let's some people like that I
like that but some some other people
don't like it maybe maybe what gets you
out of bed is it you're gonna re-watch a
Seinfeld episode or something that's
aesthetic experience alright and just
about yeah maybe I shouldn't go yeah I'm
just gonna be like what is this I'm Kim
Kardashian I'm not gonna
if you like Kim Kardashian
go get your kick out of that don't
there's no reason to dismiss that just
because you think that that's a morally
repugnant person first of all how did
you know I mean you know she's married
to Kanye West so that's a reason but but
but but it's um if if that's what's
gonna give you your daily dose of beauty
or your daily dose of aesthetic
experience you should not feel ashamed
about this this is what this is what
you're gonna this is this is important
that you have that it's not looking at
the very matter for three hours but if
you look at Kim Kardashian's butt and
that's what you're doing if you know
you're important experience then I like
there's controversy it makes it more
exciting um but no I would say I
completely agree with you I mean of
course not everyone should look at
Vermeer's and you know you can get
aesthetic pleasure for many different
things that's why I bring up simply a
leaf like I think so often we kind of
forget that there there is so much
beauty everywhere I mean look at the
place where we are like look at the the
hills and the verdant landscapes and I
mean there's so much Universal Beauty
it's almost impossible if you were
actually aware of it all to process it
because it's an overwhelming miracle and
I think part of it is that if you
haven't had a kind of an experience of
beauty in this sense where you're so
overwhelmed by the beauty of the world
that you're kind of completely
transported it's very hard to describe
it's just a pleasing oh it's nice you
know looking at this painting that's not
the beauty I'm talking about I'm talking
about something that is entirely
different than a pleasing aesthetic
experience although I would say the
definition of aesthetics is beauty it's
pleasing because it is beautiful in the
kind of traditional sense of the term so
I do think they're connected but III
would say that we have to have some sort
of value system here and I'm sorry but
Kim Kardashian's bottom is not that and
I think it's so pathetic that we have
come to say okay well we might as well
bring this into the refrigerator in a
second hanger segment I do think I'm
going to interrupt in the sense that I
think you're both talking about slightly
separate things you're talking about
things that are for free right and
you're talking about something that is
about cultural manifest manifest
churring which is interesting and i
agree a but is abut like I'm interested
in the biorhythm of thin but too fat but
too thin but too fat but like in the
sense of where we are in our political
history and actually how that gets
dictated to us as something being shown
as aspirational and I think the move is
equal in that in the sense that there
has been so much agenda around the
institution of art that we can't take it
out of that perspective right because
there has been a hierarchy now I love
art right I absolutely love art but the
makers of art can't afford their own art
and that is historically fact even today
they could not afford to buy their own
art even the wealthiest that maybe don't
damien hirst
can but he's an anomaly right
michelangelo couldn't and neither could
even Leonardo da Vinci so you have to
understand that the makers these amazing
makers who make the most incredible
embroideries who stitch and who are
stonemasons who are the people who
fabricate this brilliance they can't
afford it they could not afford to buy
the temple they can't afford to buy the
palaces they are made for other people
so yes I'm in wonder but I also am also
understanding that we are being funneled
through these social perspectives and
they're very different from commodity to
free and that is very interesting
interplay to have because actually
through the history of time we have been
worshipping the moon as a wonder right
so that goes back into the roots of our
own religious spiritual thinking and our
own language so I don't think we can see
something is simply ascetic because it
has all of this historical kind of
psychological symbolic kind of a it's
programmed into our DNA to be able to
respond to it so I think that is
interesting so yes I think beauty is a
part of existence and sometimes
beautiful is ugly
but I would just like to say that I
think sometimes there's a conflation of
the structures around beauty and beauty
itself it's true like in the modern arts
industry it's a terrible unbeautiful
thing if you do that for example you
know people can't necessarily afford
paintings like arts has been you know a
sphere for the elite but that says
nothing about the art itself unless it
perhaps was created in a like that was
the intention of the art was to be
created in this kind of elitist way or
or I mean it was around a kind of
commodified and that was the idea of the
art itself but the thing I think must be
separated from the the structures which
bind it and the way that it's made
accessible and I think once we can
separate them then we can you know
address the issue of accessibility or
the the economy or whatever other issue
but to conflate them I think is a
problem can we make that separation I
think it's problematic I mean when you
look at the church there's one of the
original forms of art that existed was
religious art that was there too as
hieroglyphics to kind of point the poor
to the right direction of thinking so
the snake had a symbol the Apple had a
symbol and they all it was a it was a
visual language so it's very hard to
kind of separate the two and that's
where I bring it back to your point
which is let's make it about us as an
individual and really help ourselves
define what is true to ourselves in
order that we can steer our own ship to
actually have our values reflected in
what we perceive is beautiful and I
think once you do that is coming from
quite an emotive place and somehow I
kind of trust emotions a little bit more
but I am so loved the ascetics I love
structure and I do think the simplicity
of structure can sometimes be divine
just for being what it is so kind of
in-between II I think what we should be
a little we should be a little less
prescriptive when it comes to beauty and
when it comes to aesthetics get your
kicks when you find them I think get
your kids where you find it thank you
for coming
[Applause]
thank you so much for listening to this
episode of philosophy for our times
podcast is brought to you by the
Institute of Arts and ideas it was
hosted by me and I Carrie and I guess
this week we're just in clutter some
erotic and bent on a please do subscribe
to make sure you never miss an episode
head over to iTunes give us that rating
review and of course tune in next week
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
institute of arts and ideas at IAI TV
you